In the last video,
we thought about how
we would allocate our $5 between
chocolate bars and fruit.
And the way we did it,
and it was very rational,
we thought about how much bang
would we get for each buck.
And we saw, look, starting
off, our first dollar
we got a lot of bang
for our buck-- and this
is really just another way
of saying bang for the buck,
marginal utility per price.
So we got a lot of utility
for price starting off
for that first chocolate bar.
A little less for the
next chocolate bar,
but still more than we would
get for a pound of fruit.
Then more for the
next chocolate bar,
and only then did
we start buying
some fruit, buying
some pounds of fruit.
What do I do in this
video is generalize it.
I want to think about maybe
a more continuous case
where we can buy very, very
small increments of each
of the products.
It doesn't have to be in
chunks, like chocolate bars.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to plot the marginal utility
per price, which is really
bang for your buck,
on the vertical axis.
So
This right over
here on this axis.
Let's say this is the
marginal utility per price.
And let's say it also
goes from 0 to 100.
So that would be 50.
And the numbers actually
don't matter so much here.
And then this will
be dollar spent.
So dollars spent, so your buck.
So this is bang for your buck
and then this is your buck.
So this is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 and 6.
Now we're going to do
arbitrary products.
So let's say one product
looks something like this.
And once again, you
have diminishing utility
as you get more and
more of that product.
In the case of fruit,
the more pounds of fruit
you get the more tired
you get of fruit.
The less fruit
you need for that,
or the less you want fruit for
that next incremental pound.
So let's-- but it
could be anything.
This is true of most things.
So this is product A,
could be a service as well.
So product A, let me
write it this way.
So this is the marginal
utility for A per price of A.
And let me get another
product right over here.
So let's say my other product
looks something like this.
So this is my marginal utility
for product B per price of B.
So it's really saying
bang for the buck.
So just to start
off-- and I won't even
constrain how much
money we have.
I just want to think about
how we would spend that money.
So if I were to spend,
if I had a penny,
where would I spend a penny.
And I'm assuming I can buy these
in super small chunks, as small
as maybe the penny or even
maybe fractions of penny.
So if I just had
a penny, and I had
to think about where
am I getting the best
bang for my buck for that
penny, I'm clearly getting it
with product A. So I would
spend that penny on product A
and I would get this much
bang for my buck, which
would be this entire
part right over here.
Let me color it in.
So my first-- I'll
spend it right on A.
Let me do it in a color
that's more likely to be seen,
so I'll do it in
this blue color.
So I'll spend it on
A. My first, in fact,
where would I spend
my first dollar?
Well, the whole first dollar
I'm getting a better bang
for my buck on A. So my first
dollar I will spend on A.
And the total utility
I will get is actually
going to be the area
under this curve.
It's going to be
this whole area.
It's going to be dollars times
marginal utility with price.
That would give you, obviously,
the area of this rectangle
right over here.
The reason why it wouldn't
be the area of this larger
rectangle, it would just be
the area under the curve,
is you're not getting 100
marginal utility per price
for the entire dollar.
It's going down the entire time.
And so your actual
total marginal utility
is actually just
the area under this.
And when you take
calculus you'll
get a better
appreciation for that.
But let's just think
about, once again, where
our dollar is going to be spent.
So actually even if
we've spent already $1,
our next penny we would still
want to spend on product A,
because we're still getting
more bang for the buck.
We're still getting more
bang for the buck all the way
until right around there.
Now something
interesting is happening.
So we've spent about $2.
We've spend our first
$2 all on product A
because we're getting
more bang for buck,
even though that bang was
diminishing every penny or even
every fraction of a
penny that we spent.
But now where will we
spend our next penny?
Well, we could spend
it on product A again.
But look, we can get about the
same marginal utility spending
it on product B. So we
could jump right over there,
spend it on product B. Now where
could we spend our next dollar?
Well, we get about the
same marginal utility
whether we spend it on a
little bit more of product B,
or a little bit more of product
A. So we could do either.
If we spent a little bit
too much on product A,
then we could have gotten
more marginal utility spending
on product B. So
what we would do
is, once we've gotten to this
threshold right about here,
we actually are going to spend
every incremental fraction
of a penny-- we're
actually going
to want to split between
product A and product
B. If we spend too much on
one and we go down this curve,
we could have gotten higher
utility spending on this one.
If we spend too
much on this one we
could get higher
utility spending
on this one right over here.
So there's a very
interesting phenomenon here.
Assuming that we
eventually spent enough
that we buy some of
both, obviously we
started just buying
product A because it
had higher utility, at least,
for those first few dollars--
but assuming that we end up
buying some mix of the two,
which we do end up spending
if we spend more than $2--
there's an interesting thing.
The marginal utility for B, or
the marginal utility for price
for B that I spent on
that last little increment
is going to be the same as
the marginal utility per price
for that last increment of
A. So if this was, if B was,
I don't know, if it was fruit
and let's say A was chocolate
but we could buy them in
very, very small increments--
we're saying for that last
fraction of a pound of fruit
you're getting the same
marginal utility per price
as you're getting for that
last fraction of a bar
or fraction of a
pound of chocolate.
So there's a general
principle over here.
And it really just comes from
this very straightforward thing
that as soon as you can
get better marginal utility
on the other one, you
start spending there.
But then they start
to look equal.
And you would keep dividing
your money between the two.
And so the general
principle, if you're
allocating money
between two goods,
for that last increment--
not across the board,
just that last increment--
that's why the word marginal
is so important.
For that last ounce of
chocolate versus that
very last ounce of fruit,
the marginal utility
for price for that last
increment of one good
will be the same as
the marginal utility
per price of the second good.
Now I really want to
emphasize what this is saying.
This is not saying that the
marginal utility for price
of the two goods are the same.
And not even that one is
better than the other.
This is just saying
as you spend money,
and let's say you spend
enough money to buy both,
at some point you're going
to get to a threshold
where you're neutral
between the two, where
the marginal
utility for price is
the same for an incremental of
B versus an incremental of A.
And at that point you're
juts going to keep switching
between the two products.
Because obviously,
if you focus too much
on this right over here--
let's say you focus,
let's say at that
point you switch
and you just start buying
a bunch of product B
right over here.
Well, that didn't make sense.
Because you were
buying product B
when you could have
actually gotten
higher marginal utility
buying some of product A.
And that's the same
reason why you didn't just
keep going down A, because
you could have gotten
higher marginal
utility over here.
This is closer to, I don't
know, 75 while you're only
getting 70 right over here.